been a lot of controversy over this
year's Academy Awards and the lack of
diversity among the nominees everyone's
talking about how to fix the diversity
issue in this town well our old friend
we have an old friend who thinks he has
solved this issue please welcome Deon
Cole
thanks Conan first of all
congratulations to all the white people
who are nominated for an Oscar and if
you didn't get nominated you must really
suck
look we all know there's a lack of black
nominees and I got a way to fix that
just add more categories to the Oscars
wait a minute you're saying you can fix
this problem by adding more categories
yeah new categories like best portrayal
of Nelson Mandela best performance by
anyone named Denzel best minority
Ghostbuster or storm true
best rap song not written by Macklemore
Best Supporting Actor in a holiday film
where Taye Diggs wears a sweater
best utterance of the line oh hell no
and of course best film set in the
barber shop or maybe the third film
about a barbershop and theaters April 15
that's right Dion you're I'm remembering
now you're in barbershop 3 Oh Emma I
must have forgotten and the correct
title is barbershop the next cut in
theaters April 15
[Applause]